Hello, everyone, thanks for the introduction.
I will be talking about Parallel JavaScript,
before I tell you more about it, why Parallel
JavaScript?
Well, simple the hardware you have is getting
more and more parallel, you have more cores,
you is wider vector units, your GPUs are increasing
in performance since 2006 there's been a 75
X increase of par are legal use‑‑ at
the same time, the kinds of applications would
you write with JavaScript has changed.
Now you have physics and fluid simulations
you have path tracing, real‑time game engines
at the same time JavaScript programs have
access to device sensors, on board sensors,
multimedia streams, so the kind of applications
are changing, many sophisticated more computing
intensive.
But there's no support for parallel computing.
Why do we wanton vent a new parallel programming
model
's so many, so many people have invented so
many, why not take it and bolt it on top of
JavaScript, right.
Turns out the web has specific requirements
that make this approach undesirable.
First thing we want to preserve is ease of
use, whatever programming, whatever parallel
programming model we use should fit in well
with JavaScript.
So the programmerrer should haven't to two
different mental model, one for the sequential
parts of the program and another for the parallel
part of the program, it should all just be
JavaScript.
We want to have a very high level API, we
don't want the programmer to worry about and
exchange primitives, or even threads, we want
a very high level API fitting with the Ethos
of JavaScript.
We want to be deterministic where possible,
this is hard for parallel programming, but
the determinism is awesome for debugging and
deployment.
We also want to be platform indent, we want
to run on all kind of platforms, from single
core, mobile phones to the most powerful desktop
computer, we want the leverage different kinds
of particularism, could be multicore or GPU,
not just that, we want the program to write
the same code for all of these different kinds
of parallelism, we don't want the programmer
to write one kind of code and another for
GPUs, e we want that to be abstract away,
our goal is to extract reasonable performance
from parallel hardware.
it's a secondary goal and this should not
be completely to the developer, the browser
Runtime should share a lot of this burden
of extracting performance, we want to make
the expression of parallelism easy but not
exactly how you implement it .
Finally we want to make it suitable for the
open web, we want to‑‑ we don't want
to increase the attack service for JavaScript,
we don't want native execution of native code
for example, we still want to preserve the
sand boxed execution environment of JavaScript,
right.
So, this is a brief overview of the Parallel
JavaScript API, it's built on 3 pillars, the
first is collections, these collections in
JavaScript are just JavaScript arrays, and,
typed object, which are going to be in an
ES 7.
Then you have high level data par are legal
methods that operate on these collections,
some of these may already be familiar, map,
reduce, filter, scatter, the PAR suffix simply
conveys the programmers intention that he
would like this method called to operate in
parallel.
It may not, as we will see, but he would like
it to be.
So very high level.
No threads.
The third component is elemental functions,
these are just regular JavaScript functions
that are the things that are execute in the
par are legal across cores, GPUs and so on,
there's one important caffuate, that have
to be side effect free, they cannot alter
global state.
So global state may for example be a global
variable, right, in a parallel region, you
not, in an elemental function, you cannot
change global state, right, you can read it,
but you cannot write to it.
To there are also more subtle kind of side
effects in JavaScript program which is are
engine level side effects, so, for example
just‑‑ two strings, though it appears
at a surface level has engine level side effects,
but it's not up to the programmer to worry
about those things, it's about the browser
Runtime were tory about that.
So let's look at some code example (To worry
about that) this is a very simple example
of how you would use the MapPar, you have
a tie any array, one, two, three, four, you
give mapPar an elemental function, that fat
arrow function over there.
And that increments each element in the input
array, this looks exactly like map, if you
load this using map it would look exactly
the same.
The different here the elemental function
is execute in the parallel for each element
in this array.
If you‑‑ of course in this case you
don't need parallelism, it's only four elements
if you is a million elements and your elemental
function is doing something more sophisticated
you imagine how this would be useful.
Reduce looks similar, you give it, again,
an elemental function that takes two values
and returns one value so you're reducing A
and B to produce B, when applied to this array
produce ten this is exactly the semantics
that normal Java can produce as well.
By adding Par you're marking it parallel
's an important caveat here, determinism,
when you do reduce, determinism is guaranteed
only when the elemental function is associated,
right, if the elemental function is not associative,
then, you'll get, you'll transparently get
sequential execution, it will be equal in
to just reduce.
In other words, the programmer does the best
job he can to write code that is paraism friendly,
if not, if it's not paraelism friendly he'll
get sequential execution, without changing
any code.
So let's say you have an input image which
is a 3 dimensional width times height times
four, right, four is RGB alpha, this is how
you would convert it into gray scale, you
do a mapPar, ignore 2 over there and give
it an elemental function that averages the
first three channels, the RGB values and returns
an array with this so this is a simple averageaing
gray scale operation.
The two here is the depth at which you want
the mapPar to operate, if you have a 3 dimensional
collection, sometimes would you like to operate
on rows of an image, sometimes would you like
the operate on fix els, sometimes would you
like to operate on individual color channels
in an image, the depth parameter would allow
you to select what slice you want to do this
parallel operation on, in an input collection,
okay.
You don't have to worry about all the details,
theu just to give you an idea of what the
APL looks like, so reversing an array, simple
exact million you create an ray for build
par‑‑ in parallel it constructs an array
that just contains 0123 and scatter Par takes
a function that maps elements in the input
array to the out put away.
ScatterPar is taking the first element putting
it in the last index and so on.
Filter works exactly the same way as‑‑
filterPar works exactly the same way as‑‑
just give it an elemental function this returns
the Boolean, it determines whether it stay
in the out put array or not.
Typed objects are a new proposal.
I believe there are‑‑ there's a preliminary
implementation in fire fox.
The API just works on typed objects I dentically
to JavaScript objects, the same gray scale
operation I showed you earlier, it's very
similar, except it's returning the JavaScript
array, you're returning a new typed object.
So, this is what I mean by feeding in with
the rest of JavaScript, you don't want to
introduce new types or concepts, you want
to kind of build upon what is already there.
Of Parallel JavaScript is an ES 7 proposal
at this point.
We're discussing the API in the committee
and with the browser‑‑ there's a specification
you can look at.
And a preliminary implementation is in fire
fox nightly the API I just showed you is the
result of a collaboration between my team
and the Mozilla team that is implements JPS
in Nightly.
So in order to get parallel execution, they
had to solve several challenges I'll briefly
describe them, first was JIT support, so you
want for parallelism you want to go in IC
side effect freedom, how do you make sure
they Donahue state global state T way they
do this is theyv a static safety analysis
that inspects your JavaScript and figures
out whether there's a violation of the side
effect freedom requirement.
They also have right guard which is are dynamic
checks that check whether you're following
the rule.
They have a pretty cool work stealing scheduler
that tries to schedule work on hardware threads
in the way that reduces imbalances on threads,
if you have hypothreading, you have many hardware
threats, it tries to keep all of them busy.
And there's a new garbage collection scheme
just for Parallel JavaScript that is kind
of integrated with the spider monkey, fire
foxes generational garbage collector, and
cool thing about this is it actually exploits
the programming model, the property of the
programming model, which is that you can't
have side effects, and this fact makes garbage
collection fast, it turns out, which is cool.
Finally there's a lot of work on providing
retail reasons for why something did not execute
in parallel.
For example in the mapPar, if I were to insert
some Dom, which is not side effect free, then
the program will bail out of parallel execution
and you'll just get sequential execution,
but your console will tell you that this is
the operation at this line number in your
program, that is the reason for you not getting
parallel speed ups, right.
They also provide complete stack frames at
bailout points so that you can actually debug
why things didn't flan parallel this is really
important‑‑ didn't run in parallel.
I would like to take a few minutes to talk
about parallel JavaScript on GPUs, hugely
important resource that I think we should
use more in JavaScript programs in the non‑graphical
portions of JavaScript programs, I mean GPGPU,
general programming context.
But, compiling Parallel JavaScript to GPUs
is not easy, it's challenging,I I'llout line
a few reasons why, GPUs have a separate address
space than CPU,‑‑ how do you make that
available to a JavaScript program running
on the GPU?
You have copy it, which would be hugely expensive
otherwise you would have to map it somehow.
So this is a non‑trivial problem.
Even though in some new chips, physical memory
is shared, virtual memory is not shared, this
makes the problem of mapping non‑contiguous
parts of the heap on your device very challenging.
Then there are a number of paths to the actual
GPU hardware, there's directX,there's openCL
Kernels and there are tons more.
Each of these have slightly different semantics,
each of these is‑‑ allows a different
subset of JavaScript, so I'm talking about
compiling JavaScript to one of these, right.
So, as you can imagine, you can compile a
different subset of JavaScript, so you have
to reconcile these together in your browser
Runtime.
So, some things that would be possible to
express in, let's say openCL would not be
possible to express in OpenGL, right, just
because of the programming model.
You have to keep that in mind when you're
compiling.
Then there's no dynamic location on northwest
GPUs there, is no notion overheap, as such,
it's just scratch pad memory, the star there
indicates that on kind of more recent GPUs
there is actually, I think Kuda, 2.0 has Mallac,
it's not wide limply meanted on all GPUs,
there's no general notion of a stack either,
rite on a GPU, so most interesting JavaScript
programs would like to do heap allocations,
I presume, this would be hard to support,
you would have to build a dynamic memory managerrer,
and a collector that runs completely on the
GPU.
There are also no function pointers in most
GPU programming models, this makes things
like dynamic dispatch difficult to impresent.
And polymorphism is also difficult oimpresent.
And getting final performance is not easy,
the developer has to keep track of different
families of GPUs, this is a fourth generation
GPU with Open CL, and this is a Coda, so it's
very, it's an intractable problem and unreasonable
to expect the programmer to keep track of
all of these things.
So our approach is to basically take this
high level specification in PGS and let the
browser Runtime‑‑ the browser Runtime
has perfect knowledge of what the platform
is, it can query GP capabilities, it can do
all of that, the idea is to threat browser
run time do it, transparently.
We've implemented a back end that takes your
JavaScript and compiles it to run on GPU,
we have impresented it within fire fox.
So, this is an overview of what it looks like,
the blue parts are what would happen with
normal parallel Java execution, CPU, would
you run for a little while with an at the
present timer, baseline JIT, once your code
has been hit a few times, it's hot, you know
all the type information, then you would go
to the Ion monkey JIT that would spend more
time optimizing, it's that the point doing
parallel safety analysis, checking to see
if it's safe to run in parallel or not.
Then lower it a few times then you get just
native code,right.
In the GPU case, we take MIR, which is the
mid‑level intermediary rep evennation in
JavaScript in Ion monkey, we do GPU specific
safety analysis, this checke checks whether
all the byte codes can be supported on the
GPU, for example, if you're compiling to GSLL,
then maybe some particular byte codes are
not supported
are no equal lens in GLL for some Java code.
Then we do some simple type inference, this
is basically taking the JIT, ION monkey git
information and translating it to type that
open CL understands, and we do some optimizations
for exploiting local memory, which is very
fast on GPs, and then finally we generate
open CL, and then Open CL is built into a
CPU binary and we reuse that binary, as long
as type information doesn't change, the types
flowing your you JavaScript program doesn't
change, the Kernel is valid and we keep reusing
it.
So what does all of this buy us, right?
Let's look at the energy and‑‑ let's
look at performance first, verse parallel
execution on a CPU, remember, the baseline
here is Parallel JavaScript execution on a
CPU, which is already depending on mow cores
you is, which is already faster than regular
sequential JavaScript, right.
So the blue access, the blue white access
performance relative to CPU, so these are‑‑
these are some simple benchmarks that I picked.
We have more, I can show them to you later,
so this MM is dense matrix, it does 8 times
better than on the GPU than on parallel CPU,
this is written in JavaScript using PGS, and
2D‑Conv which you use for image sharpening,
finding contours or optical flow, it's a fairly
important ‑‑ it does 2.8 times faster
on GPU than parallel CP, you all know the
Mandel set, it does 6.2 times better in terms
of performance than CPU.
What about energy?
So for dense matrix multiply, GPU execution
the 7.7 times lower in energy than CPU execution,
than parallel CPU execution, it's 3 times
and Mandel is 7.7 times lower, not only are
you getting huge increases from par are legal
execution on GPU, over what is already fast
parallel CP um, you're also getting huge decrees
in total energy consumption, this is big.
The matrix multiplier programs runs‑‑
runs 22 times faster.
So this 8 X is over that.
Ever 6‑‑ this would be 2.8 times faster
than that.
Okay.
Let me quickly show you a quick demo‑‑
this is a simple program of so there are a
burner bunch of bugs the goal of the game
is to move them using my hand to the frog,
feed them to the frog or take them to their
house, right.
So, I probably should be standing closer,
so, it's using‑‑ it's doing optical
flow on the image stream captured by the camera
to basically figure out which way I'm moving
so you can see tall bugs settling on my face
(Laughing) so it basically detects changes
in energy in the image.
So if I were to just run the sequential version
of this today.
It would run like this.
Right this is pretty slow.
Let's go back to the parallel version.
(Applause) so, let me go back to my presentation,
I can show you this in more detail, if you're
interested.
Okay, so the implementation is in fire fox
Nightly there's a ECMA script proposal, we
would like the feedback, this is the time
to influence when the API looks like and how
it's specified, if you is comments write to
me or participate in the discussion on ECMAS
discuss.
Try it out and let us know what you think.
Thank you (applause)